-Guys, since we're back at home,
I thought it would be fun
to do another installment
of "Ask the Fallons."
This where my wife Nancy and I
answer questions
that you guys send in.
It could be about us or the kids
or life or anything.
So here's another
"Ask the Fallons."
-♪ Ask the Fallons,
Ask the Fallons ♪
-Okay.
Well, we're back.
-Yeah.
-It's been one year. [ Laughs ]
-It's been a year.
-I thought I was out.
[ Laughs ]
I totally did
my civic showbiz duty.
-Honey.
-And yet here I am again.
-Did I publicly thank you?
-A year later in the same coat.
-I don't know if I did.
-Alright, we have
a bunch of questions
from everyone
who watches the show.
And people really like this bit
that we did
where it's us just walking
around and talking.
Alright. Here's one of these.
This is interesting.
-Okay.
-Who said "I love you" first?
Where and when did it happen?
Do you want to plug your ears
and I'll tell my version?
-No, no. Oh, yeah. I wonder
if our version is the same.
-We kind of do this
on the show with other --
So maybe plug your ears,
and I'll say it real quick.
-Okay.
-And maybe hum something.
-Oh, I see.
♪ La, la, la, la, la ♪
-Alright, I said "I love you"
in London.
We were a press thing
for "Fever Pitch."
Nancy's a producer.
We just would hang out in
the hotel all the time,
listen to music, Harry Nelson,
Randy Newman.
And I put on "Taxi," which is
my favorite show.
-New fence!
-And I made her watch this show
about their dreams or something,
and it was just good.
And then we kissed.
We were in my hotel room,
we kissed for the first time,
and it was honestly
the best kiss I've ever had
in my life.
And I think I said
"I love you" after that.
Alright. That's my story.
Honey, I'm done.
[ Clears throat ] I'm done, hon.
-Okay.
-Alright.
Who said --
-Who said "I love you"? He did.
And we had been having big
crushes on each other
during "Fever Pitch."
And like two awesome nerds,
we didn't do anything about it
but flirt a lot and listen to
a lot of music
and say, like, good night
at 4:00 in the morning
like total nerd balls.
-I'm a pretty smooth dude.
-Okay.
So we wrapped the movie,
"Fever Pitch,"
and we were going to London
to sell it,
and we went out
one really fun night
and, um, we ended up -- -
-Halloween, wasn't it?
-No, that was in London.
That was our first kiss.
But our first "I love you"
was in London.
And I had to leave the next day.
I was there for the press
junket, and then I had to leave,
and I think you all
were going somewhere.
But that night, he said,
"I love you.
I'm in love with you."
And I don't even know
if I said it back
because I think you knew
that I loved you.
So I think that then --
-Wow.
-Well, maybe I did, but I don't
think it was like,
"I love you, I love you,
I love you."
You were like, "I love you."
And then I flew home
the next day,
and I will never forget
that flight.
I had to go back to California.
And you know that feeling when
you're just smiling ear to ear
and it's just the best feeling
in the world
when you, like, love someone
and they love you
and you have a crush
and it's reciprocated?
And...that's my memory.
And then I feel like
from there --
-I told the wrong story.
-[ Laughs ]
-I thought it was first kiss.
I confused the two.
-[ Gasps ] Oh, no.
First kiss, Boston.
Yeah. Oh! When we levitated?
-That was a good kiss.
-That was the best kiss
I've ever had.
So that was two stories --
an "I love you" --
-Yeah. You got two stories
out of that one.
-Yeah. And yeah.
-I don't know what story
you got.
That was the "I love you" story.
[ Geese honking ]
-Hi, guys.
-Wow.
-I just wanted to thank you
for doing these walks and talks.
And I want to thank everyone
who's watching for enjoying --
-Yeah.
We should really thank them.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
Really.
This is -- it's been fun.
-It has been fun.
A little glimpse into...
-Yeah.
-...Jimmy and his wife.
-Love you, cutie.
-I love you.
You're welcome.
-Alright, do you want another?
[ Chuckles ]
Did you throw in a little
"You're welcome" there?
-Yeah! Just said,
"You're welcome."
-That's what she does
every time we kiss.
She says, "You're welcome."
-No! You said thank you.
[ Laughs ]
That would be so good.
-That's the way
our relationship is.
-Oh, my God.
You're welcome.
"Honey, I love you."
"You're welcome."
[ Both laugh ]
-Alright, you want to do
another question?
-Yeah.
-What's your go-to recipe
for a night in?
Ready? One, two, three.
-Takeout.
[ Both laugh ]
Did Nancy's family
accept Jimmy immediately?
-[ Laughs ]
No, no. Of course.
I'm laughing.
-I didn't get to the end.
-Our New Hampshire weekend.
-It was honestly --
-We had a "meet the parents"
weekend.
-My parents came to visit
Nancy's parents
for the first time
in New Hampshire.
-It was the first meeting
of everybody.
-Couldn't have been
a bigger disaster.
-We decided not to do a dinner.
"Why don't we do
an entire weekend together?"
[ Laughs ]
Because what could
go wrong there?
There's not a story
that could go wrong.
-The night before, my mother
calls me and she goes,
"Jimmy, don't hang up."
That's the signal for,
"You're gonna get angry
at what I'm about to say."
I go, "What do you mean?
Hi, Mom. How are you?
First of all, hi."
"Alright, don't hang up."
I go, "I heard you."
She goes,
"Mm-kay, not a big deal,
but Daddy's tooth
fell out today," or last night
or something.
"His front tooth fell out."
I go, "His front tooth?"
-Front. Not a back or anything
that you could hide.
-I go, "Go to the dentist.
Get a cap or get something."
She goes, "The dentist
is on vacation."
I go, "This is a di--
You can't come meet --
This is Nancy's family.
You can't meet them
with no teeth."
She goes, "It's fine.
Daddy's just not gonna smile."
-He just won't smile.
[ Laughs ]
-"Not gonna smile?
What are you talking about?
This is a weekend."
I go, "I'm hanging up,"
I was that mad.
She goes, "Well, don't hang up.
Wait, wait, one more thing.
I rubbed my eye
in my sleep last night,
and I have a bloody eye."
I go,
"You've got to be kidding me."
So here, meet my parents,
a pirate and a Jack-O-Lantern.
-Yeah.
-My mom would be laughing.
She would be laughing.
-Oh, she would be laughing so --
Are you kidding?
This is the best story ever.
-Exactly. She loved it.
So, it was probably
April, March.
It was --
The lake was just done --
-The ice was out,
but it was very cold.
-My dad goes, "I'm gonna jump
in the lake," to be funny.
-Yeah.
-Anyway, so we go,
"Alright, let's get ready.
We're gonna go out to dinner."
So we're getting ready
to go out for dinner.
Mind you, my mom had bad knees,
and she could --
-Kind of not bend ankle or knee,
really, in a way.
-I don't know if her knee's bad
or her ankles.
Nothing quite -- It was very
interesting, how she walked.
So anyways, we were upstairs,
getting ready for dinner,
and there's a knock on the door
where we were getting ready,
and I go, "It can't be.
It can't be my mom because" --
-She couldn't get up
those stairs, right?
-There's no way.
So she comes up the stairs,
and we kind of smell smoke.
-Uh-huh. As we open the door,
we smell.
-We open the door, smell smoke,
she goes,
"Everything's fine."
-"Don't worry."
-"Everything's fine."
I go, "What's going on?
What's happening?"
She goes, "Daddy jumped in
the lake with all his money."
-A wad of...
-20s.
-...I don't know, fives?
-$20 bills. I think it was $500,
maybe, or $200.
-Just a wad.
-$500 of $20 bills.
She goes,
"And so his money got wet."
And so he tried
to dry his money.
My dad put $500
in the microwave...
-In our microwave.
-..and lit the money on fire.
[ Both laugh ]
This is one story.
-And this is just a reminder.
-An old lake house.
-The old family --
It's not valuable, but it is
invaluable to the hearts.
[ Laughs ]
-I go down, there's $20 bills
laid all over the kitchen
with brown burnt spots.
I go, "Dad, what --"
He's like, "I didn't realize,
I thought you could
dry the money."
I go...
There's metal in $20 bills,
apparently, like a strip.
-Just FYI -- don't put money
in the microwave.
-Honey, that's one story, but --
-That was one of a few.
-You still married me.
-Yes, we weren't married,
were we?
Yeah, no, that's -- Aww!
-You're so lucky.
-I'm so lucky.
-Mwah! You're welcome.
Mwah! You're welcome.
[ Both laugh ]
-Mwah! You are welcome, honey.
-Thank you so much
for those questions, you guys.